♪♪
Ok! You all want to play chase?
Charge!
Father:
Hey Jill,
O-ho-ho!
Jill: Woow!
These buddies need to go
outside.
The new baby's gonna need your
sister Jacky's room to sleep
in.
Hi ya!
Jacky's noisier than my
animals.
(Laughing)
Jill:
It's going to be your comfy new
home.
(Quack, quack, quack,)
If you need help, just ask me.
Quackety, duck, duck.
♪♪
Piotr Michael:
Welcome to lovely little farm.
These animals will grow up just
fine out here.
Pony:
Oh yeah, Jill, if you still
brush my tail,
so it looks this good.
..Heee.
Piotr Michael:
Where everyone cares for one
another...
Jill:
We're going to be the most
caring, sharing big sisters ever.
Piotr Michael:
...big...
We did it!
Piotr Michael:
...and small.
Hello little lamb.
♪♪
Awww.
♪Let's go.♪
Piotr Michael:
Life on a farm
isn't alway easy.
Jill:
Come on, this way.
Piotr Michael:
But a little love goes a long
way.
Jill:
How's egg collecting?
Jacky:
It's really tricky.
I could try and help.
Jill:
One hand gently underneath.
Thanks, Jill.
♪♪
Alpaca:
Glad we've got you, farmer Jill.
Awww!
Pony:
Double glad.
I've never been happier.
I love my little farm.
♪♪